and for jorge lopez he had faced the uh
the astros since 2019 where they roughed
him up
see altuv as hot as anybody here and he
gets him
and then throws him a change up not an
easy guy to get out is a good way to
start the game for jorge lopez
and down he goes 97 heater to 83 on the
breaking ball
bradley at second guriel down at first
two down
[Applause]
so they throw it down to first to
complete the strikeout
lopez strikes out the side zach greinke
is the right-hander for your houston
astros
starting against the team that he has
not faced since 2010
15 starts this season and 91 in the
third innings only 19 walks to the 66
strikeouts
trey mancini will bat and lock up
comeback player of the year in the first
half but here's the ground ball to short
robel garcia to jose altuve altuve the
quick turn
zach grenke dials up a double play
ground ball after the hit
by freddie galvez miles straw
astro center fielder hitting 250 323 on
base percentage a home run and 23 rbis
the two won the straw and straw drills
it deep to left field hayes is going
back at the wall
he leads and it's off his glove is that
ball in play
it is straw is at second base with a
double
straw with his hands out he thought
maybe that cleared the wall
hayes got plenty of glove on that but
couldn't come up with it and may have
prevented that from leaving the ballpark
take a look at that hands out
oh touch the fan yeah it hit the fan
that's a home run
hit the top of the wall and then
ricocheted off the fan and came back
they're gonna take a look at this in
baltimore
we're talking about the home run derby
and all of a sudden here is miles straw
putting one out there
to say when let's see the call there we
go
miles straw gets his third career home
run his
second in camden yards
opens ahead a ball and two strikes
breaking ball one hopper
galvez up with it fires across and they
get him
freddie galvez hang a few stars on that
one
he just hits it like a rocket and
look at freddie from his knees what a
play
garcia at third two down lopez ready
full count pitch on the way
tap to second valencia charging and he
gets him
nice play valencia had to go a long way
astros down
in the third
there's a shot velaka's got one in the
gap in right center
severino around second he'll get to
third
and the orioles with runners on the
corners here with one down in the third
[Applause]
there it is again lined into center
severino tags at third nice play by
straw
severino will score on the sac fly and
the game's tied at 1.
they're going to get the sacrifice fly
but that easily
that ball looked like it knuckled could
have been more than that
ball on the strike bounce to second
valleca charges
tags throws double play
good here turns the double play alvarez
not the swiftest of
hitters zach's doing a good job with the
double play balls behind him
using that defense could he get
another one here tough toss from i'll do
it
but a good turn by robel garcia for the
double play
al dube with a big smile
straw counting for the astros run his
first time up with a home run that just
cleared the wall and left
with mccormick at first base on a 3-2
count there he goes the pitch is sent
into right field coming on is stewart
and he makes an attempt at the ball but
it's in play mccormick's going to go
around third base and try to score
he'll be safe with a head first slide
mccormick never stopped running on that
ball that was
in and out of the glove of dj stewart
and the astros take a 2-1 lead
miles straw two of the fastest guys on
this team and a check swing is the
first amazing part of this but it
actually gets put in play and just out
of the reach of stuart as he lays out
and then chaz mccormick never giving up
on this and just
going put his head down as stewart tried
to get back to the baseball
mccormick has enough time to slide in
safely
full count zach grenke off the first
base out of the rubber
on three and two
[Applause]
well center field racing back
and it's off the wall mancini
running hard around second and he'll
stop there with a double
probably a good thing another change up
why not go with your best pitch
here's the pitch change up got him
strike three greinke gets franco
and they strand the runner on second
base what a great job of pitching by
zach grinky
the astros lead 2-1 as we go to the 8th
inning
where the bases loaded nobody out 8th
inning
astros at the plate 1-2
on the way hit hard galvez comes to the
plate
and they get the out what a play by
freddy
well you know i mean it's a seed
and it almost knocked him down he's
playing in and then
we've seen it already from shortstop
when he throws it
falling down
chas sends one high and deep to left
field deep enough to score a run
guriel tagging up catch made by austin
hayes yuli will
head home the astros now lead three to
one chaz mccormick the sac fly rbi
nicely done
[Applause]
presley after starting out the inning
3-0 has battled back
to a couple of strikeouts
into center field playable milestraw
waits for it
the astros have a nine-game winning
streak
longest winning streak for houston since
the 2019
team had a couple of 10 game winning
streaks
plummer this team continues to roll
along tonight was a tight game but they
win it 3-1
yeah they're finding ways to win you
love it when they go out there and blast
other teams and put up big numbers and
get us excited but there are going to be
moments where you're going to have to go
out there and play some of these tight
ball games
zach cranky gave him a great seven and a
third innings pitch a couple of big hits
and a couple of rbis from miles straw
helping the astros get their
eighth victory in a row as this winning
streak continues